great white sharks
is there any sea beast so feared by
humans
great whites like these here off the
coast of South Africa in an area called
false Bay can reach 20 feet in length
and weigh up to 5,000 pounds that's more
than a pickup truck but slightly less
than a luxury SUV add this to the fact
that great whites can sprint through the
water at speeds up to 43 miles per hour
and it's no wonder we're afraid of
sharks but should we be I mean let's
face it they have great vision they're
curious like cats and they love to taste
things that get their attention but many
scientists believe they don't like to
eat humans they feel about humans the
way most humans feel about lima beans
there's something to eat out of
desperation the fact is great whites
sometimes taste humans for the same
reason they taste other things like
motors or boats they're ampullae of
Lorenzini prompt them to taste it
of course the ampullae of Lorenzini are
gel-filled electro receptors found all
around the Sharks snout and head that's
these smaller pores you see here these
receptors are extremely sensitive to
electrical discharges even as small as
point zero zero five micro volts that
means anything that gives off the
tiniest electrical charge has to be
checked out including all living
creatures in the sea forget humans and
motorboats
if you want to see when great white
sharks flip over literally let's talk
about seals we know that some whale
species engage in what's called
breaching leaping out of the water but
did you know great white sharks can
breach as well look at these false pay
great whites put on a show as they go
after a seal decoy being pulled by a
boat if humans are lima beans to sharks
then seals are a double hot fudge ice
cream sundae with three cherries on top
luckily we're yeah lima beans